madame monsieur bonsoir laurent fabius
et georgina dufoix ont donc été relaxé
par la cour de justice de la république
à l'issue du procès du sang contaminé
edmond hervé a quant à lui été condamné
mais dispensé de peine les trois anciens
ministres étaient jugés pour homicides
involontaires et risque jusqu'à trois
ans de prison reportage chez les demis
et de nos villes
laurent fabius est sorti blanchi de son
procès selon la cour de justice le
dépistage du sida en france a été
réalisée sans retard le premier ministre
a lui-même accélérer le processus
l'ancien ministre des affaires sociales
georgina dufoix et elle aussi relaxé
selon les juges en 85 elle n'a retardé
aucune mesure nécessaire à la lutte
contre le sida elle est soulagée
nouvelles de relaxer forcément une bonne
nouvelle c'est une nouvelle qu'elle
attendait avec confiance depuis de
nombreuses années il ne reste qu'un
coupable c'est edmond hervé les juges
estiment que le secrétaire d'état à la
santé aurait dû imposer le test ou la
destruction de tous les produits
sanguins prélevés avant le dépistage il
est condamné pour négligence et condamné
mais dispensé de peine motif la cour
relève que sa présomption d'innocence a
été malmené depuis 15 ans elle n'a pas
eu le courage
de me relaxer totalement
et elle n'a pas eu le courage
de me condamner réellement
cette décision qui est injuste obtenu je
viens de le savoir par 8 voix
contre 7
montre que la politique partisane
l'a emporté sur la justice et sur le
droit sylvie roui est une des deux
seules victimes dont la contamination
est imputée à izmir mais la décision de
la cour ne l'a pas apaisé pour moi hervé
c'est sûr est coupable de ma
contamination mais il n'était pas le
seul est ce que je me suis rendu compte
c'est que les politiques passées comme
les gangsters si on les prend pas la
main dans le sac
il fut jamais les coincer les témoins
ont été choisis il n'y a pas eu
d'accusations donc en ce qui concerne le
retard dans la mise en place du test de
dépistage il demeure de mon point de vue
un doute les plaignants ont aussi du mal
à digérer le fait qu'eads - hervé soit
dispensé de peine des protestations ont
accueilli cette décision ça allait nous
faire aujourd'hui après responsable mais
pas coupable mais coupable et pas
condamnable je trouve que c'est encore
graff le premier arrêt de la cour de
justice de la république a donc beaucoup
déçu les plaignants laurent fabius en
revanche se dit dans un bref communiqué
satisfait et ému que la vérité était et
reconnu